what chance saw and heard on tuesday
afternoon will likely haunt him forever
el salvador ramos stormed into robb
elementary school he and his friends hid
and waited to be rescued everybody was
scared
we were all panicking because we didn't
know what was really happening what we
saw were thousands of police and barbara
troll coming into the cafeteria
and we were all hiding behind a stage
in the cafeteria when it had
been all that we saw were like
policemen nothing else helped like
helicopters on the police
just
going everywhere
outside those who'd managed to get out
stood with desperate parents and police
they watched on as more children ran for
safety
the seeming lack of news and movement
from officers angered parents with some
wanting to charge in
eighteen-year-old ramos left his house
went to his grandmother's home and shot
her she was airlifted to hospital
it's believed he traveled in this truck
and crashed outside of the school
building
ramos wearing body armor is then seen
with a long rifle and backpack at the
school entrance
he went into a classroom locked the door
and opened fire
he was inside for up to an hour
during that time he murdered 19 children
and two teachers
one of the victims was nine-year-old
eliana garcia the helper around the
house who loved cheerleading and
basketball her family are heartbroken
that she'll never get to have her dream
quinceanera
from my understanding she had a dress
picked out and everything
so
i'm gonna have to buy that dress the one
that she wanted and we're gonna we're
gonna hang it up in her quinceanera
whenever the time comes i get both up
there so
she's never gonna be forgotten she's a
big part of our family
the gunman lived nearby his mother's
partner in shock says ramos was a
recluse who didn't have any friends
i'm just dead man i got something
shocked
i don't know what to think
the motive of this horrifying act of
violence is yet to be determined that
after the worst u.s school shooting for
nearly a decade there will need to be
answers ashley harinac sky news